[Musica]
oggi ci faremo due domande e le risposte
che ci daremo decreteranno il futuro
dell'intera razza umana
giusto per partire con un po di
pressione si legge di basi sulla luna di
colonie su marte e alcuni di voi
penseranno che questo sia un sogno da
bambino pura fantascienza ma la
fantascienza la scienza di domani
seguitemi in questo esercizio proviamo
ad immaginare come sarà la nostra
società tra 500 anni non tra dieci o
trecento non dove vivranno i nostri
figli oi figli dei nostri figli
ma dove saranno i pronipoti dei nostri
pronipoti e chiaramente difficile
impossibile pensare che tecnologie
useremo tra 500 anni trenta anni fa non
avevamo neanche cellulari ma ragionevole
pensare che tra 500 anni viaggeremo
nello spazio avremo insediamenti su
altri pianeti ci potremo spostare da un
pianeta all'altro
proprio come oggi prendiamo un aereo
andiamo in un altro strato magari
proprio per incontrare i nostri figli ed
è altrettanto ragionevole pensare che
non ci arriveremo in un sol botto ci
sarà un percorso da fare un percorso
costellato costellato di innovazioni
tecnologiche anche di tanti insuccessi
ma grandi passi in avanti dell'umanità e
che questo percorso sarà iniziato da
oggi a 500 anni nel futuro quindi la
prima domanda è perché non farlo
iniziare oggi questo percorso perché non
oggi
se ci pensate negli ultimi 60 anni
abbiamo lanciato sonde ad esplorare
sistema solare abbiamo messo l'uomo
sulla luna
lo space shuttle in 60 anni abbiamo
lanciato quasi 7mila satelliti che ci
hanno cambiato la vita
e tutto questo sopportato da ingenti
investimenti governativi che hanno
permesso di creare quello che noi oggi
chiamiamo mercato spaziale e questo
mercato sta cambiando
oggi sta cambiando quasi 7mila satelliti
in 60 anni più di 55.000 satelliti nei
prossimi dieci anni una crescita
esponenziale e tutti questi satelliti
saranno lanciati da aziende private
negli ultimi cinque anni sono nate più
di 400 aziende
tutte supportate da capitali privati che
oggi stanno lanciando satellite attorno
alla terra per erogare servizi a noi qui
che ci migliorino la vita da internet
internet of things nel servizi
meteorologici monitoraggio dai disastri
naturali
oggi con i dati satellitari potete fare
di tutto vi faccio un esempio in puglia
i pescatori oggi possono scegliere
quando uscire in mare dove andare a
pescare i molluschi al giusto grado di
maturazione e quando venderli sul
mercato al miglior prezzo possibile
tutto questo grazie a servizi
satellitari metereologici di
osservazione della terra e anche i dati
di borsa oggi veramente un momento
storico siamo un momento di svolta
siamo i blocchi di partenza di questo
percorso verso il nostro futuro e magari
voi state pensando si bellissimo questi
servizi che ci ci aiutano c migliorano
la vita la luna marte ma dov'è la
fregatura dove stanno i problemi gli
ostacoli che dobbiamo superare perché di
problemi in effetti ci sono e come
spesso succede ci sono dei problemi che
ci siamo creati noi ad esempio il
problema dell'immondizia spaziale questi
7.000 satelliti li abbiamo lasciati in
orbita qualcuno nel frattempo esploso
altri sono andati a sbattere uno contro
l'altro generando centinaia di milioni
di frammenti che viaggiano a 30.000
chilometri all'ora e oggi mettono a
repentaglio tutto l'ecosistema spaziale
e quindi anche il nostro percorso verso
il futuro ma anche ricordiamoci che
questo mercato molto giovane
mancano le infrastrutture che permettano
di fare questo viaggio
qui vediamo una nave cargo un camion e
un aereo da trasporto
cosa manca secondo voi in questa
immagine manca proprio il trasporto
spaziale un servizio di logistica
evoluta che aiuti non solo chi oggi sta
lanciando satelliti attorno alla terra
per aiutarci qui noi ma che abiliti
tutto quello che verrà dopo
e noi oggi la logistica la diamo un po
per scontata qui sulla terra
eppure senza servizi di logistica non ci
sarebbero aziende immaginate anche chi
produce e penne a sfera ha bisogno che
qualcuno va dalla fabbrica prenda le
penne le porti al distributore poi
via via fino al negozio la cartoleria
dove voi potete comprarlo ad un prezzo
ragionevole o anche se qualcuno di voi
domani deve prendere un aereo da torino
verso parigi è improbabile che metta la
propria automobile dentro l'aereo invece
che magari prendere un taxi un altro
servizio di trasporto una volta arrivato
all'aeroporto
ecco la logistica è un servizio
abilitante e la logistica spaziale e
quello che ci permetterà di costruire il
percorso verso quei 500 anni del futuro
e vi devo dire che questo servizio oggi
esiste già quello che vedete è un
satellite cargo che è possibile riempire
con decine di satelliti ed è in grado di
portarli esattamente dove servono per
poter fare il loro lavoro in qualsiasi
punto dello spazio un po come fa il
furgoncino delle poste quando da torino
prendeva a roma milano napoli a
consegnare i pacchi
questo permette oggi di risparmiare la
85 per cento del tempo dal lancio di un
satellite a quando questo satellite
pronte ad erogare proprio servizio e un
40 per cento dei costi oggi agli
operatori satellitari
quello che vedete è un video girato dal
cargo dal furgoncino delle poste
ok mentre rilascia uno di questi pacchi
uno di questi satelliti che è pronto ad
operare questo è il primo servizio
commerciale di trasporto satelliti mai
esistito ed è stato inventato da
un'azienda italiana ma non solo servizio
di trasporti satelliti se ci saranno
satelliti che hanno bisogno di carri
attrezzi spaziali che vadano dai
satelliti in panne o che portino alla
benzina quei satelliti che l'hanno
finita
ho ancora un carro attrezzi che vada da
quei satelliti che ormai sono a fine
vita e li rimuova in modo sicuro andando
a risolvere quindi il problema
dell'immondizia spaziale
ma facciamo un altro passo in avanti con
tutti questi satelliti che stiamo
lanciando ci sarà bisogno di un sacco di
furgoncini spaziale un sacco di carl
attrezzi spaziali
ecco tutti questi verranno costruiti in
orbita e se ci pensate abbastanza logico
noi le navi non le costruiamo nei
deserti per poi trascinarla in mare
quindi perché i satelliti dobbiamo farli
a terra per poi utilizzarle nello spazio
e se state pensando sì ma la materia
prima per costruirli beh vi ricordate
l'immondizia spaziale benvenuti
nell'economia spaziale circolare tutti
questi satelliti in disuso un giorno
potranno essere opportunamente riciclati
e poi magari utilizzando proprio
stampanti 3d si potranno costruire nuovi
pezzi che saranno assemblati da sistemi
robotici intelligenti quindi oggi è un
po più facile pensare come potremmo
riuscire ad andare a vivere su altri
pianeti ed è anche un po più facile
credere quando si legge sui giornali di
colonie su marte anche se il termine
colonia vuol dire un insediamento
stabile che si auto sostiene non è
proprio il termine che io utilizzerei
oggi chiaramente non fraintendiamoci su
marte ci andremo questa è una certezza
ed è anche probabile che metteremo dei
moduli abitabili
ma questi moduli avranno bisogno di
risorse gli approvvigionamenti e sarà
così costoso mantenerli che nessuno
stato nessuna nessuna azienda al mondo
riuscirà a farlo a lungo termine
anche in questo caso servirà un servizio
di logistica un servizio di
approvvigionamento che colleghi marte
con la terra la luna e la fascia degli
asteroidi un po come avviene per i
servizi cargo i servizi di traghetto che
collegano le isole di un arcipelago
quindi bellissimo questo futuro che ci
aspetta con questi servizi che ci
miglioreranno la vita lungo un percorso
costellato di sfide ma anche di
innovazione
un percorso che sarà abilitato da un
servizio di logistica intelligente e un
percorso che possiamo scegliere noi
quando far partire che in realtà se
vogliamo è già partito ma non abbiamo
detto come percorreremo questa strada
non abbiamo detto come l'uomo si
espanderà nello spazio e vedete ci sono
diversi scenari che possiamo andare ad
analizzare ma se volessimo riassumerli
in tre macro scenari arriveremo a questi
il primo scenario è quello delle locuste
quindi l'essere umano come uno sciame di
locuste ha depredato tutte le risorse
naturali che oggi ci tengono in vita e
quindi si sposta di pianeta in pianeta
depredando spostandosi e così via
pensando che tanto l'universo è grande
poi magari un giorno scoprire che forse
non era proprio così
secondo scenario è quello dell'asteroide
oggi ci sono decine di asteroidi che
minacciano di colpire la terra sono
costantemente monitorati
quindi la razza umana preoccupate da
questa minaccia di estinzione globale
che cosa fa si duplica e diciamo basso
altri pianeti in modo tale da ridurre la
probabilità di estinzione della specie
umana e lo fa in modo assolutamente
uguale creando tante terre tutte uguali
che hanno fatto gli stessi percorsi gli
stessi sbagli un po come oggi si va in
un fast food di una catena di
franchising quindi tutte con la stessa
modalità fino a un certo punto trovarsi
anche loro ogni singola terra di fronte
al dilemma benissimo adesso quale
scenario ci aspetta e poi infine c'è lo
scenario quello buono giusto dove l'uomo
spinto dal proprio istinto di
esploratore va verso lo spazio
migliorando la vita di tutti applicando
concetti di economia circolare e quindi
un'economia non ad impatto zero ma
addirittura rigenerativa che migliori la
vita quindi la mia seconda domanda è
quale scenario ci aspetta qual è lo
scenario che ci troveremo di fronte il
primo quello delle locuste
se ci guardiamo intorno forse un po
locuste lo stiamo già facendo
o il secondo in cui continueremo a
ripercorrere sempre gli stessi errori
e chiaro che questi due scenari ci
porteranno inevitabilmente
all'estinzione
l'universo non è abbastanza grande per
una civiltà che non sa imparare dai
propri errori
e a farne le spese saranno i figli dei
nostri figli ma fermiamoci un attimo
abbiamo detto che il percorso verso il
futuro
possiamo scegliere noi quando partire
allora forse possiamo scegliere anche
come percorrerlo e possiamo scegliere
come sarà lo scenario che ci aspetta
possiamo deciderlo disegnarlo
progettarlo e questa una scelta della
nostra civiltà e la civiltà è fatta di
persone quindi in realtà una scelta
nostra una scelta dei singoli individui
di quello che facciamo tutti i giorni
dell'educazione che diamo i nostri figli
è la nostra scelta di essere di
diventare l'esempio che vogliamo seguire
perché vedete non ci sarà
luna marte l'universo per noi non ci
sarà per i nostri figli o per i figli
dei nostri figli se non vogliamo che ci
sia e volere prendere questa decisione
non è poi così difficile basta applicare
quelle
concetto che a prima vista sembra
sofisticato qualcuno lo chiama
sostenibilità qualcun'altro economia
circolare economia rigenerativa
io lo chiamo buon senso quindi domani
mattina quando vi alzate
cosa farete per creare un futuro capace
di futuro
grazie
[Applauso]